introducing three-time golden did award
champion winner of the hammy for best
original custard the stuff face magazine
man of the year he was also employee of
the month once in a Denny's in 2006 it's
my honor to present to you
hello friends and welcome to another
fun-filled episode of the walking dead
I'm your new host Brian would you look
at that I guess it's time to get cooking
this episode is brought to you by colon
art productions today's recipe idea
comes from the user see grooves cook he
says we're gonna make some delicious
bloody sundays ah damn right we are who
let going on set security security out
here Dave I gave them tickets to dead
air on ice we're not doing show with you
Gordon get out I'm not going anywhere I
think it'd be fun to have a guest host
on the show he just tried to kill you
I'm sure it was all in good fun yeah
Dave quit being a party pooper what no
just look this is unbelievable
for this super cool recipe you're gonna
need the following items ice cream
whipped cream cherries chocolate and
strawberry syrup and a banana and human
blood what the [ __ ] was that very funny
Gordon but we're gonna use this to chop
up the banana oh no you're doing it all
wrong you have to do it like this what's
this is my show I think we ought to do
it my way what do you mean your show
it's called the walking dead for
Buddhist sake I'll tell you what since
you're a guest on my show we can each
make one you do yours your way and I'll
do mine my way Oh fine whatever what do
you say we make this a bit more
interesting we'll find a random person
to judge our service and if I win I did
a sander show as a co-host ok Kip but if
I win you're off the show and you
sacrifice all your recipes mean we put
in my new cookbook Brian's cookbook
right it's called Brian's cookbook no
bad pun no tagline fine what you got
yourself a deal chef Brian
okay gay the first step for my Sunday as
always is to wash your hands to get rid
of those yucky germs screw that I've
been washed my hands in years no just
flatten out the top of your ice cream I
like to scoop my ice cream into a big
eyeball like this incidentally this is a
great tool for scooping out someone's
actual eyeball next up we're gonna add
our two banana slices this should add
some appeal to your sunday you should
make like a banana and kill yourself at
Ryan a real chef would dip their banana
slices in a chocolate like this and
place it right here then you can stab it
in the eye with a toothpick incidentally
toothpicks are great tools for stabbing
someone in the actual now it's time to
whip up some features I like to whip my
cream myself incidentally this is also a
great tool for torturing someone where's
Dave anyways I'm just gonna grab this
bottle up your move Brian let me just
get open really hurt Gordon not as bad
as it's gonna hurt when you lose Brian I
hope you've all placed your lips
carefully now run the syrup down the
ridges
go straight down there perfect now just
cut a cherry half gimme holes
now I like to add pure vanilla even
though it's vanilla ice cream already
it's just so good I'm gonna add a bit of
blood to finish off my bloody sunday no
you're doing it all wrong give me that
you have to do it like this Don alrighty
it wasn't that fun I really realized
over the course of this episode I hate
you okay I'm afraid that's all we have
time for on this episode but tune in
next time to see to the winner is and
don't forget to vote where do they do
that in that comment of course it's
gonna be me hopeful as always try these
recipes in your own kitchen and you're
all and all thanks for watching and
we'll see you mr.
I can't take this anymore Gordon has
pissed me off for the last time
I have to call in reinforcements
I have to call the FDA
you
you